it's a Thursday edition of PFT p.m. for
my fairly new studio here in my office
I've realized it's a hell of a lot
easier to just sit where I work keep the
place reasonably clean plug in a
microphone press the appropriate button
and off we go and off we go
today with all the important and latest
news in the National Football League and
I want to start with the chatter that's
still out there about Antonio Brown
potentially joining the Seahawks there
was a video recently of Brown working
out with Russel Wilson look this
connection has been out there for a
while now remember last year when the
Seahawks signed Josh Borden the report
was that it was basically going to be
Gordon or Antonio Brown and they went
with Gordon in part because Gordon they
knew they would immediately get on the
field of Antonio Brown there was this
lingering sense all of last season that
if anyone signed him he'd immediately be
put on the Commissioner exempt list
based upon pending investigations for
violation of the personal conduct policy
well here we are now nearly ten months
after the lawsuit originally filed
against Antonio Brown that created the
specter of the Commissioner exempt list
there were two other incidents after
that there was the alleged harassment
via text message of a woman who came
forward to si.com with some details of a
separate incident involving Brown and
then there was the incident earlier this
year with the driver of a moving truck
down in Florida Brown recently pleaded
no contest to felony charges in
connection with that incident so the end
result is if the Seahawks are just
didn't Brown they have no idea when he's
going to be available nobody knows when
he's going to be available nobody knows
what kind of a suspension he's going to
get no one knows what the league will do
for the most recent incident and when
you plead no contest you're still going
to get some sort of punishment and my
guest based upon precedent would be four
to six games from that alone and then
there's the incident of harassment what
do they do for that if they determine it
happened and then the big one is the
alleged sexual assault and rape that was
never reduced to a criminal complaint
but was brought and is pending in a
civil proceeding but
regardless of whatever legal standard
applies before the court of roger
goodell and obviously it's not beyond a
reasonable doubt it's a lower bar there
isn't a middle ground here either the
league is going to conclude that brown
did it or he didn't do it so if they
believe the alleged victim when they
believe him they're more likely to find
he did it and if they find that he
committed sexual assault and/or rape
especially if they find he committed
rape how do I ever let him play in the
NFL again and the thing is it's all
still pending one of the problems I have
with a personal conduct policy there are
no dates there are no deadlines there is
no trigger there is no requirement that
an investigation be completed within 60
days of its commencement it can linger
forever and the Union has no ability to
fight back and that's the way the
personal conduct policy has always been
the people out there that want to dump
on NF OPA executive director - Morris
Smith say well he allowed that to be
created enough it already existed so in
order to change it you have to be
willing to make some other concession
elsewhere that's what these myth
inherited and look I say this all the
time as it relates to the personal
conduct policy how much does every
player want to give up for something
that helps on average two or three
players per year now it potentially
could affect any of them but as a
practical matter it's a very small
fraction of the entire rank and file
that ends up being affected by these
things so how much do you give up to
help an Antonio Brown or the next day
Antonio Brown or the next Antonio Brown
there's a fat one per year now I still
think that the NFL should fix the policy
just as a matter of what is the right
thing to do in a situation like this and
I'll say this the right thing to do
this suspended for 2020 all or part of
the season he should get credit for the
14 games he missed last year because his
posture as relates to the possible
placement of commission or exempt list
kept teams away from signing him plain
and simple
he became radioactive he has served a
de-facto 14 game unpaid suspension since
this issue first came up and since the
Patriots cut him after the second
incident the alleged harassment via text
message of the woman who came forward to
si.com once that came out that's when
the Patriots moved on he was unsigned
the rest of the year unemployed the rest
of the year and it's all because the NFL
would never come out and say yes he'll
be on the commissioner exempt list no he
won't it was the perfect atmosphere to
scare people away from signing Antonio
Brown the end result is he's missed 14
games period so if he gets suspended 16
games this year well he should get
credit for 14 even gets suspended 12 day
you can do the math I can't bottom line
is he should get credit for those games
so yes it looks like the Seahawks are
interested but no there's no clarity as
to win he'll be able to play and yes I
believe whatever happens with the one
resolved incident at least as the
criminal courts are concerned the two
other pending incidents as it relates to
the NFL all of those things whatever the
punishment is he should get credit for
the 14 games that he essentially served
last year in the form of an unpaid
suspension all right speaking the NFL
and it's habit of handing out penalties
both the Patriots and the league office
benefited from the fact that just about
five or ten minutes before or before
five or ten minutes after the Cam Newton
news broke on Sunday night came the leak
came the report that the NFL had
punished the Patriots for Spygate 3 I
don't know Spygate whatever Spygate
December 2019 the Browns Bengals game a
week before the Patriots were due to
play the Bengals a video crew in the
press box taping the sidelines of the
sense
nattie bangles created a big mess
patriots quickly admitted to it that the
patriots said all along this has nothing
to do with our football operations and
there were multiple reports that there's
no evidence connecting the patriots
video crew to the football operation and
I said from the beginning look that's
what the investigation needs to focus on
establishing any new link any tentacles
between football operations and the
video crew and if you find it that's
when the antennae go up that's when you
get very aggressive by trying to prove
that there was a side assignment that
was given to these individuals or that
it was all just a ruse it was a cover
for an effort to go into the press box
and take video of the Bengals sideline
so I've never seen anything to suggest
that there was any connection between
the video crew and football operations
I've seen no reports to suggest it and
I'm told there is no proof and I
remember hearing back in December when
the investigation got started that the
investigators were getting frustrated
with some of the Patriots witnesses
because they couldn't prove that there
was a link they wanted to prove a link
that was the perception that some of the
people who were being interviewed got so
here we are the news comes out Sunday
night of the punishment and when you
look at it here's what happened there
was no statement from the league I went
looking this morning for the statement
from the league or the article in the
NFL calm or anything that would tell us
why the NFL did would did what evidence
in ultimately gleaned in order to
support the conclusion and there's
nothing all the NFL did was confirm the
reporting that appeared separately on
Sunday night no explanation of the
evidence no explanation of the reasons
for the punishment based upon the
evidence no analysis of how past
Patriots incidents may have affected the
final decision no comparison of this
incident to other incidents from recent
years and remember fairly early in the
process there were multiple reports
suggesting that the punishment would be
similar to what other teams experienced
for similar incidents that was coming
from the league office that wasn't
something that the reporter
just pulling out of the air somebody the
lead office was saying hey here's how
it's gonna go down and when you look at
the similar incidents that were
mentioned in reports by people like Adam
Schefter VSP and mark masky at the
Washington Post it seems like the
Patriots for what they did ended up
getting a lot worse because when you
look at the incidents that have happened
in recent years and I'm just gonna take
a couple of them brief are more the
former Browns Jim when he texts it down
to the sidelines during games in blatant
violation of the rules the falcons
piping in fake crowd noise in blatant
violation of the rules with a clear
effort to get a strategic advantage
Ben McAdoo remember when he was using a
walkie talkie on the sidelines blatant
violation the rules and clearly
something that was aimed at advancing
the agenda of trying to win the football
game he wasn't ordering another case of
Brylcreem right it had something to do
with the game there was a benefit to be
derived the difference here is it has
never been established that anything
done by that video crew was ever going
to benefit the football team if you
can't show a connection between a video
crew and the football operations how do
you show that the Patriots were even
cheating they broke the rules
technically but without that link that's
where that link was so critical the link
from the video crew back to football
operations if you can't establish that
link there's nothing that comes from it
that ever could have come from it that
would have helped the Patriots prepare
for and beat the Bengals that's what
makes this case different from all the
other ones because all the other cases
had a clear Nexus had a clear connection
between conduct and strategic benefit no
strategic benefit here but still 1.1
million dollar fine third-round draft
pick those were the major penalties
imposed on the Patriots and although I
want and if you're with any team in the
NFL the Patriots or any of the other 31
including the Bengals you want to know
what they did to trigger the punishment
what's the connection one of the
fundamental purposes of any type of a
criminal justice system what
public or private you want to deter
others from engaging in similar behavior
but without transparency how does anyone
know what behavior to avoid what did the
Patriots do to justify 1.1 million and a
third-round pick did you find a
connection to football operations we
don't know did you find that there was
some potential strategic advantage to be
gained
we don't know did you find that this
video crew had a habit of showing up the
week before every opponent that the
Patriots were due to play last year we
don't know and all of it was accidental
I don't think it was laziness I don't
think it was people are on vacation and
nobody wanted to put it together I think
the NFL wanted to do what it wanted to
do and that's what the NFL does all the
time now often what happens is the NFL
picks its resolution and works backward
in this case it just picked its
resolution and didn't bother to work
backward forward or in any direction the
report was made of what the punishment
is the NFL confirmed it and no one has
provided any type of analysis and we're
not asking for much here they know what
the evidence was they know why they did
what they did are they concerned than if
they explain it it's not gonna hold up
under questioning are they concerned
that it's illogical that it's unfair are
they concerned that they just decided
they don't like the Patriots and this is
what we're going to do Patriots should
known better any team out there the
patron should know better you know what
if that's the argument go ahead and lay
that out see my belief is this in a
setting like this when you are
disciplining organizations when you're
taking away a draft pick any draft pick
but a third-round draft pick pretty
significant draft pick you have a duty
to all of the teams and to the media and
the fans to be fully transparent and let
people know why you're doing what you're
doing and when you choose not to be
transparent the inescapable conclusion
is you're up to something you're up to
no good you're trying to conceal why you
did what you did because you don't want
those decisions and that reasoning to be
exposed to the light of day because you
know if it is it's not gonna look good
but who knows how it's gonna look
because they hit it they've concealed it
they have found a way
keep the Patriots and everyone else from
knowing exactly why the NFL did what it
did
why not tell everyone why you did what
you did why not lay out the evidence why
not let everyone know exactly what it is
they got the Patriots in trouble
especially since the Patriots and every
other team now need to know going
forward what it is that will get them in
trouble it's simple and it's frustrating
that me as somebody who follows the
league covers the league and analyze the
decisions made by the league has no
opportunity to even begin to understand
the connection between what we know and
what the league did and I think there's
got to be something to bridge that gap
and without it it's impossible to
understand why the league did what it
did or what will get similar teams in
similar circumstances in similar
predicaments in the future dana snyder
the Washington owner has a predicament
it's unclear whether he's acknowledged
that to himself or anyone else but the
pressure is continuing to mount on
Snyder changed the name of his team to
developments from Wednesday
at 87 investment firms that represent
620 billion in assets putting pressure
on Nike Pepsi and FedEx to stop doing
business with the Washington franchise
until it changes its name now FedEx is
important here because FedEx Field is
the name of the place where the team
plays and also Fred Smith the CEO of
FedEx is one of the owners of the
franchise if you start putting pressure
on Fred Smith and maybe he puts pressure
on daniel snyder maybe right maybe so
all those three companies I think FedEx
is the one that people need to focus on
if you want to get the attention
eventually of Dan Schneider but this is
the first time this issues been hanging
around for seven years now this is the
first time there's been any type of
pressure placed upon the sponsors of the
franchise also and this one has kind of
been percolating out there we've known
it's going this way but forget about
having a new stadium on the side of RFK
Stadium unless and until the name
changed that's something that Snyder
would like to do and part of the bargain
is going to be give up the name now look
the cynical side of me has believed it's
Snyder is just holding back changing the
name so he can leverage it for some
tangible benefit whether it's more money
to build a stadium whether it's a draft
in DC whether it's an open air cold
weather Super Bowl in DC whatever the
case may be I feel like he's been
holding it back for the right time to
trade it for something and by saying as
he did several years ago all caps never
will he change the name that just puffs
up the value of the thing that he
eventually would turn in for some
consideration coming back to him but in
this moment it's not like he's gonna get
anything in return for doing it the
question is will there be enough
pressure put on him that he has to do
something now to end this discussion I
still don't know whether or not the
discussion is even registered and it
astounds me that he doesn't see the
parallels between himself and George
Preston Marshall that 40 or 50 years
from now Snyder will be getting the same
kind of treatment that Marshall is
getting now of course Snyder hasn't done
anything to merit a monument or
placement in the ring up on or anything
like that so it's not like the
is anything that would be tangible that
could be taken away years from now but
you don't wanna be remember that way so
I just don't know what the endgame here
is for the team other than I believe to
run out the clock and hope that
eventually we'll all move on to
something else and the franchise will be
allowed to continue with a name that is
a dictionary to find racial slur but
that no one is applying the kind of
pressure on Schneider to get him to
change engine period including the
league I don't know what's going on
behind the scenes but I haven't heard
anything if the NFL was intent on
getting him to change the name and if
the NFL was talking to him behind the
scenes somebody from the league office
would leave that to reporters because
that allows the NFL to look good they
don't look like they're being
disrespectful they're not going public
but sources with knowledge of the
situation have confirmed that yada yada
yada
that's a way to get it out there the
league is doing something right now the
league is doing nothing and I think the
league is complicit and people have said
to me well why are you giving Ron Rivera
hard time about this whoa he's the only
guy who's out there talk Schneider is
nowhere to be seen
Rivera was on radio in Chicago three
days ago and he said that the issue of
the name changes a discussion for
another time we criticize him for that
because if now is at the time when it's
well why are you giving Ron Rivera our
time he's just an employee well he has
said he's the leader of the franchise
and he's empowered to run the
organization and he believes actions
speak louder than words so I think he is
somebody who could be singled out but
secondly Snyder's not doing these
interviews Snyder's not making himself
available
Snyder's not answering any of these
questions think about what he said back
in 2013 when he said put it down in all
caps I'll never change the name think of
how that would go over if he would do it
now that's why he's not saying anything
and I continue to hold out hope that
players will eventually say something
that's the next frontier in all of this
you start having people who are employed
by the organization and who will stand
up and talk now look I'm gonna get the
same reaction why are you putting
pressure on these guys they're just
trying to get a paycheck they're just
trying to play football why do you want
them to say something well what's gonna
happen I gonna get cut if Dwayne Haskins
says something see gonna get benched if
Adrian Peterson says something is he
gonna get
cut Terry Maclaurin chase young you
think chase young is gonna suffer any
consequences whatsoever if he says you
know I've been thinking about this and
chase young he's a very conscientious
young man
chase young decided that he wasn't gonna
work out at the combine he wasn't gonna
give in to the pressure that gets put on
these players to entertain the rest of
us
in late February when there's no
football going on he understands the
business if he has a moment of
conscience why couldn't he say yeah I
don't think that's a good name I think
they need to change it I think that's
the next frontier the question is will
the name change now will it change later
and what will be the legacy of the
people who participated and enabled the
ongoing existence of this name beyond
this moment forget about the last seven
years this is the moment where the
change needs to happen this does the
reckoning and awakening on all matters
of race this is the time for it to
happen and the clock is ticking loud
like and legacies are on the line and
we'll see if anybody steps up and does
the right thing all right NFL looking at
cutting the preseason in half we
reported that yesterday week one week
four gone the other two weeks will
likely be reconfigured so everybody has
one home game in one road game and we
said before that's important because you
want everyone have a chance to go
through the motions of getting ready to
play a game at home with pandemic
protocols in place go on the road and
play a game with pandemic protocols in
place there have been reports that the
NFL PA hasn't signed off on that yet but
there are counter reports that the NFL
is determined to play two preseason
games we'll see what happens but I'd be
stunned if there are fewer than two
preseason games and that leads into my
next point everything that's going on
right now between the NFL me NFL Players
Association is negotiable we see once
every five or ten years the league in
the Union negotiate a collective
bargaining agreement from start to
finish top to bottom inside and out
lengthy detailed document that is the
product of months and months and months
of negotiation basically what they're
going to be doing soon I hope is
creating a collective bargaining
agreement for one season for 2020 here's
what we're going to do to
try to play a season in a pandemic and
all of these issues are on the tape you
know you look at the current CBA and I
was having this conversation with
someone last night because somebody said
oh the changing conditions of the
pandemic require the parties to go to
the bargaining table and negotiate a new
deal no they know no they don't the
Union ratified the current agreement
during the pandemic if the league wanted
to do it and if the Union wanted to do
it they just say we go forward we don't
do anything off we go we have an
agreement in place now as a reality the
NFL is going to want to do some things
differently things that would give rise
to a duty to bargain you change the
working conditions by wanting to do
certain things to protect people to
fulfill the obligation to provide a safe
workplace that unlocks the duty to sit
down and talk it forever so to the
extent that the union wants one
preseason game or no preseason games
that's just one of the concessions that
would have to be made the union says we
won't know preseason games fine what
does the league want see the Union
doesn't get to walk in and dictate
everything here this isn't Spalding and
Caddyshack going up to the snack bar
saying I want this I want that I want
that but on the same token this isn't
judge smell saying you'll get nothing
and like it there's a middle ground here
and the challenge is getting it all done
before July 28th and actually getting it
done before July 19 because that's when
the work ease can be required to show up
for their coronavirus test conditioning
for rookie starts two days later on the
21st injured veterans show up for their
coronavirus test conditioning for them
starts two days later culminating in
testing of healthy veterans on July 26
for the coronavirus and then full
training camp on the 28th now I know
that there are teams considering just
having everyone show up on the 28th
because they're scrambling to get their
facility ready for training camp given
the pandemic requirements but bottom
line is there is not much time for the
lis in the Union to work out whatever it
is they're going to work out they have a
lot of issues there's a lot of sub
issues and there's a lot of sub sub
issues as JC treasurer said ever
question that's resolved leads to three
more questions and it just spirals out
of control and they have to figure out
all of these issues and I feel like one
of the reasons they've delayed is that
well first of all it's a deadline-driven
business but he had a lot of work to do
with his deadline approaching but second
I think that they were hoping that there
would be more evidence more data from
other sports returning to play and the
reality is the major sports aren't going
to be back before it's time to show up
for training camp and if they are back
beforehand I don't have the actual firm
if there is a firm timeline for NHL MLB
or NBA but it's gonna be close even if
the other sports start before July 28th
they're not gonna be starting that much
before July 28th than anything
meaningful can come out of that that
will help guide the NFL so bottom line
is is a lot to do there's not much time
within which to do it
and both some in good faith with the
goal of getting this fixed now isn't the
time to settle old scores now is it the
time to try to make the last deal a
little bit better now isn't the time to
be thinking about 2021 concessions for
future years they get folded back into
this year focus on this year focus on
the procedures for this year and get it
done or we're gonna have a problem and
it's all going to get delayed and then
media's gonna take sides fans are gonna
take sides gonna be a big mess and it's
already a big mess but it's got the
potential be an even bigger mess if the
league in the Union can't make some
agreements quickly on what this season
is going to look like
alright last topic and this relates to
college football and I thought of this
earlier today because of the
announcement from USC that they will be
encouraging undergraduate students to
take their classes this year exclusively
online and discouraging undergraduate
students from living on or near campus
meanwhile campus is still going to be
open see you can't have college football
without college and a lot of these
schools are going to try to thread this
needle where they really don't have
College but they have
nuf college to justify playing college
football it's unfortunate but it's
reality because all of these programs
yes they want to balance the safety of
their students but it's got to be
balanced against mac maximizing revenue
and college football makes too much
money especially when you don't have to
pay the players and it caused me to
wonder who is going to protect the
players here they don't have a union
like the NFL players do the schools
aren't going to protect them that is the
ultimate fox guarding the hen house and
the NCAA has checked out on this we had
a story about that over the weekend a
mother of a Notre Dame player concerned
about the fact that Notre Dame is doing
everything the right way and their first
opponent of the year Arkansas isn't
they're only testing players who show
symptoms or who have been directly
exposed to someone who's positive for
the virus that's it so somebody needs to
be taking care of these kids and there's
no one in the position to do it and I
don't know what's going to come of it
now look the one thing that could be
done and it's going to require the
players to stand up to their coach but
you find a lawyer who can put together a
lawsuit with yeah you don't have to have
every players name on the lawsuit to
potentially put the brakes on a program
that may not have safe procedures in
place but if you throw together a
complaint for injunctive relief you put
together a motion for preliminary
injunction coupled with a motion for a
temporary restraining order and you can
go into court your prior to go into
federal court you you don't want to be
the elected judge at the state level who
pulls the plug on the popular local
university football program or you ain't
gonna win the next time you're up for
election you want to go to a federal
judge who's appointed for life and you
file that federal lawsuit and you seek
that federal injunction that shuts down
the program until certain protocols
definitely are satisfied that's really
all the players have and the problem is
a lot of the players don't care a lot of
them just don't care
they should care a lot in Belk care so
to be able to see if any of the schools
that are by all appearances plowing
ahead with football will be facing
resistance from players and will
specifically be facing some sort of
litigation compelling the organization's
to do what they should do anyway which
is take care of these kids especially
since they are basically free labor they
already take all of the risks that are
associated with playing full-contact
football at a very high level now on top
of that they're gonna be assuming the
risks of contracting the coronavirus and
possibly passing it to family members
possibly family members who were
vulnerable possibly family members who
will die it's not an acceptable
situation and that's a big difference
between college and pro there's a union
in place to protect the players there's
nothing in place to protect college
football players here's hoping than
someone eventually well that's it for
Thursday's PSU p.m. we'll do it again to
wrap up the week on Friday
check us out around the clock at Pro
Football Talk comm everybody have a
great day
you